on a tous été injurié nous avec ce que
nous disons ce soir nous allons
probablement nous prendre des menaces au
moins au moins de cassage de gueule sur
les réseaux sociaux jouent ça me laisse
tout à fait très tranquille pour le
moment donc il ya là je me tourne vers
le jury a menacé de casser la gueule à
quelqu'un ça tombe sous le coup du droit
au moins citer à lui casser la gueule
donc la législation actuelle suffit les
moyens vous avez parfaitement raison
parce que on est une poignée à se faire
injurier et qui a des tas d'organisation
ou même des ong qui poursuivent les
auteurs de livres
c'est à une disproportion de les
condamnations sont elles sont
scandaleuses relation pardon devenue la
législation aujourd'hui c'est patent de
réprimer la haine on l'appelle à la
violence effectivement vous avez raison
ça soit c'est évidemment sanctionner la
question c'est plutôt de dire comment
honda sur la liberté d'opinion way parce
que quelle que soit l'opinion c'est un
droit fondamental
c'est la déclaration des droits de
l'homme de 1789 c'est quelque chose qui
est consubstantielle à une démocratie et
donc la question aujourd'hui avec une
évolution morale où on a cette liberté
d'opinion où elle est garantie n a
jamais eu autant protégé par les
décisions de justice la cour de
cassation la cour européenne des droits
de l'homme protège aujourd'hui
véritablement la liberté d'opinion et le
corpus jurisprudentielle est de ce point
de vue là tout à fait rassurant le
problème c'est que la question se
déplacent nous un autre terrain c'est
plus la sanction judiciaire c'est une
sanction qui est beaucoup plus
insidieuse ce sont des pressions qui
sont exercées sur des rédactions
ce sont des pressions qui sont exercées
très indirectement parfois pour empêcher
l'expression de quelqu'un c'est pas
cette personne là qui elle-même va faire
l'objet de pression mais ce sont les
médias qui sont là pour relayer cette
liberté d'opinion qui vont se parler
effectivement eu
[Musique]